so you moved in with your girlfriend
yeah now that you're stuck in the
apartment together there are rats in the
walls his toilet is backing up the pipe
smells so bad there's a reek in his
apartment does the reek still exist my
math yeah it's still here
the Med says he and Mary get in little
fights once a day they snapped at each
other the other morning memento Mary -
take a deep breath and calm down that's
the worst thing you could do in a fight
dude don't you hate that so we haven't
been sleeping obviously there's like
poop smell there's rats in the walls
they're dying he snores he farts all the
time there are positives to living with
me but here's the thing when you fight
with a woman and you say take a chill
pill calm down that drives them nuts
ma'amed
that is not fighting right now and I
will show you a couple days lying to you
they argue over things like keeping the
apartment neat and feeding the cats are
you doing the bulk of the work Mary you
do 85% that's working on himself and
you're taking care of the apartment are
you guys buying any of that are you
really you believe this is true yes is
it true you guys get into a fight once a
day we have one fight a day I would say
not to talk it out and I apologize
constantly Mary you're making a face
that I've never seen before
tell me tell me what's going through
your head asthma met describes this is
there really a fight every day when
there's it's like get your underwear off
the syracuse like why is that even there
that kind of oh I really wish you could
look downstairs right now whose clothes
are on the floor because I'm telling you
you
today it's your cause I did all of my
lawn Jensen and you have and that
laundry on Sunday was the first time
laundry has been done by you in like two
months well I'm gonna bring up something
that Mary said and I and I feel for her
in this and I want to say this to all
men listening ma'amed is only showering
every other day she does not always
shower after working out
I don't always smell when I sweat sure
you do she doesn't need another bad
smell the man right she's got a dump and
you mentioned he burps and farts and
smells but met you wait till you get
married to start doing that stuff why
are you farting in front of her
seriously he goes to sleep like a
trombone
you say in his sleep he's farting on you
all the time he's a dream farter well
this is what's going on during this
isolation I wish you luck you lovely
couple I know you're working hard it
really is fine we're good it's just you
know we need this pandemic to end soon
yeah we'll take a shower it'll be a lot
better